olmeta madame marie-christine dalloz
merci monsieur le président la question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
traditionnellement le mois de janvier et
le consacrer aux voeux est le chef de
l'état n'a pas failli à cette tradition
mais nous pouvons constater que cette
année particulièrement la facture est
lourde et salé et langages la france non
seulement pour l'exercice 2016 mais
aussi pour la prochaine mandature 2016
2019 2020 ce qui est pour le moins
surprenant première annonce le plan
d'urgence pour l'emploi
le 18 janvier il s'élève à 2 milliards
d'euros
l'actualisation de la loi de
programmation militaire 7 milliards de
2016 à 2019 dont 2,2 milliards sur
l'exercice 2016 généralisation du
service civique annonces faites lors des
voeux à la jeunesse et aux forces de
l'engagement c'est un milliard d'euros
dont 150 millions à minima pour 2016
le plan d'urgence pour l'agriculture les
éleveurs 290 millions immédiatement
du moins il faut l'espérer le président
a également annoncé 1 milliards au
profit de la tunisie mais a décaissé sur
cinq ans quant aux financements alloués
à l'action de la france pour le climat
la fourchette se situe entre 3 et 5
milliards d'euros d'ici à 2020 voilà le
résultat non exhaustif des voeux du
président sheikh veut mais fort
naturellement janvier fini et peut-être
allons-nous enfin connaître précisément
le véritable coût de ces annonces
je rappelle monsieur le premier ministre
que votre gouvernement inscrit dans le
projet de loi de finances 2016 une
réduction des dépenses pour un total de
16 milliards d'euros
or les dépenses nouvelles annoncées se
situe entre 5 et 7 milliards
paradoxalement vous avez annoncé
vous avez rappelé l'objectif de 50
milliards d'économies sur la période
2015 2017
où est la vérité comment peut-on
sérieusement faire autant d'annonce de
dépenses nouvelles en assurant tenir le
cap du déficit et plus généralement
quelle sera la crédibilité au niveau
national comme international de la str6
la parole est à monsieur christian
eckert secrétaire d'état chargé du
budget
sur le président mesdames messieurs les
députés madame la députée
marie-christine dalloz
vous êtes ainsi dû à nos débats
budgétaires
il faut le dire c'est pourquoi votre
question m'étonne comment pouvez vous
cherchez à instiller le doute en
prétendant que des dépenses que le
parlement à voter clairement voté vous
n'avez pas fait mais le parlement l'a
votée vous parlez de la loi de
programmation militaire
mais toutes les dépenses relatives à la
loi de programmation militaire ont été
intégrées dans le budget pour l'année
vous parlez du des mesures en faveur de
la lutte contre le terrorisme
toutes ces dépenses ont été introduites
lors de nos débats budgétaires
vous nous parlez de service civique
mais les dépenses relatives au service
civique ont été inclus dans nos
projections budgétaires et le parlement
les a votés
alors vous avez raison sur un point
madame dalloz parce que vous ne pourrez
pas avoir tort surtout sur un point vous
avez raison le président de la
république a annoncé deux milliards a
engagé en 2016
sur le plan pour l'emploi concernant la
formation et l'encouragement al embauche
dans les pme vous aurez dans les
prochaines semaines
comme nous vous l'avons toujours fait le
détail du financement de ces mesures
nous l'avons fait l'année dernière pour
le plan de lutte contre le terrorisme
nous l'avons fait régulièrement en cours
d'année en dégageant des économies sans
influence sur notre trajectoire
budgétaire
voilà madame laddh dalloz la réalité des
choses
merci la parole est à monsieur